se suponía que ayudaría a la unión
europea a acelerar su campaña de
vacunación pero ahora se ha cuestionado
la efectividad del fármaco de
astrazéneca justo antes de que el
regulador del bloque esté listo para
probarlo los funcionarios de salud
alemanes han recomendado que no se
administre el medicamento a personas
mayores de 65 años las vuelven de
ayudantes sabemos desde el otoño ya que
este debate se ha presentado durante
varios meses que con astrazéneca hay
menos datos de estudios con grupos de
mayor edad no se trata de datos malos
sino de poco en aldeas con gates en
respuesta astrazéneca defendió su vacuna
al igual que reino unido que la ha
estado usando en el programa de
inmunización masiva en el país durante
semanas
nuestras propias autoridades han dejado
muy claro que piensan que la vacuna de
oxford es muy buena y eficaz
creen que es eficaz en todos los grupos
de edad y prost
la farmacéutica anunció la semana pasada
que no podría entregar los 80 millones
de dosis esperados a europa en el primer
trimestre citando inconvenientes de
producción en una planta en bélgica sin
embargo este viernes dijo que ofrecería
8 millones de dosis adicionales al
bloque los retrasos en la entrega han
enfurecido a la unión europea pero las
dos partes prometieron trabajar juntas
para resolver el problema